you know when to welcome to this video
[Music]
do we have to doubt that this is the
right way to pronounce it
no I actually have game sounds which I
didn't have in recording before I don't
know if that is annoying the tick tick
tock stuff we just takes with an idea
this is not really precise but it's the
kind of imprecision that only leads to
equality he'll not like like being
better hmm you know he allows this which
is kind of strange because I mean II 43
is highly desirable for black so a
little bit surprising because of the
fact that the D to know it and the F to
us they are both hanging so this is
going to be a pretty substantial
concession on white spot if he moves the
night now I have capture captures in
tonight g4 on 94 immediately but then
the F pawn might move so I'm going to
take my development is not that great is
something to keep in mind
yeah but 94 he has to go you know he has
to go look f3 basically to cover you
three yeah but it's not that clear that
this is actually all that all that great
to be honest it's not clear okay I can
also just complete development I mean
that whole transformation I think is
quite quite okay for me so I'm not in a
real rush to do anything with no g4 yeah
he's got c4 maybe lined up
yeah I think I'm going to place his five
in this position and then knight c6 next
I want a bit of pressure here if he goes
efore knight c6 I would like to have
this pawn pressurizing the center so
that maybe he is inclined to push the e
pawn okay Wendy three okay let's go
knight c6 you always have to consider
what happens if they attack on c6 but
this is a move I cannot quite believe in
with the light squares weakened that
much that should not really be a concern
how to do this the bishop on c8 is not
doing anything in good here
okay he's fed up with Knight g4 and
looking at this the whole time you know
Knight age 5 has a pretty obvious idea
but don't quite know him if I go Knight
B form
where's he putting the Queen actually
it's not so easy ff9 if caught so him so
if he goes a Queen e2 90 force is quite
quite quite unpleasant to say the least
because let's say Queen e2 94 okay 395
blunder stage reborn or the exchange and
he has to somehow cover III and now I'm
getting I'm getting the bishop yeah okay
um take take takes on c5 takes on c5
Knight 65
that's a bit of a pain but you want to
do that an idea form just looks
extremely attractive Jake
he can take c5 and then immediately my
knight is hanging that's really a shame
taketake night eggs still want to do it
it's going to go a3 next year and it's a
shame really really AM lots of time
burned for all this I know I can I mean
absolutely no question
how'd you get get get at this I can go
here actually and c4 is the tech that's
just a double attack and Queen takes c4
is annoying very annoying
plus he probably has to go g4 which is
kind of a painful move anyhow but the
most important thing is if I get c4 I
get the d5 square okay so yeah that's
not going to go into stent g3 is hanging
c4 is hanging everything is hanging yeah
it's got no play will move really don't
see one
yeah that it was a bit of a disaster
yeah I think he played this tattoo
quickly after him I mean this is
slightly inaccurate yeah this is a snide
Biddy to white should take with the
Queen but okay it's not it's not a huge
mistake I had just played against me by
a grandmaster just like roughly a year
ago and it's an equal ish but nothing
special the reason why this is not so
great as the night is just not good only
to I mean just not a well-placed piece
now you have to spend time to relocate
it okay d6 we should be to e5 and here
white should probably react to that in
43 idea the engine here actually plays
wants to play Knight everyone this is
not such a bad regrouping putting the
night here and it stops no the pawn I
mean okay this is not leading to not
losing I'm not winning or anything but I
think it's quite comfortable
interestingly the engine wants to play
Knight to g5 which is quite interesting
so III I already think I'm fine yeah
clue b3 this is shocking
that's quite shocking so yeah this is
this okay well I'm really not worried
about that but it's probably quite from
the equal like if I do this and I takes
takes takes castles this should be
roughly equal I mean why this much
better developed but I mean what do you
attack here
my position is weakness completely
devoid of any weaknesses but it wasn't
all that great then I mean I was
thinking like after you for I'm fine but
95 okay this is but this is even more
remarkable that this is the move well
you mean
hmm the purpose is clear but I just did
not anticipate anything like that so if
I grab this when the engine by now is
giving giving like an advantage probably
because there is some issue with the
Queen which definitely has no squares
see 6 cm and the engine is starting to
like black you get the idea is probably
just Queen c7 9 PT 7 and I'm a piece up
ok so this is better than 91 damn you 3
my team take take and in fact this is
not as great as I thought I mean
originally thought you just hear it
after group f3 I don't really have any
great concrete continuation so probably
castles isn't too bad
Queen d3 and I went to c5 I want the
pawn to attack the the center because I
was always thinking he wanted to play
some before but okay that's not really
great now anyway you three then knight
c6 and now this moves h3 yeah he was
worried about 94 which I understand but
it weakens even more not before Queen d2
and now this was a bit of a shame I mean
and at the end I played leaving the
means that the engine has on the right
of it this is what you I'm sorry what
you wanted you the issue is you will
take Queen takes takes on c5 and now
this is a bit of a bit of a pain because
I cannot take here oh I was thinking a
looksie one but the engine points out
that this is winning the night
immediately okay so that that is not
take a ball and also takes take I
calculated this far and I thought okay
this is no good as rook c1 but okay the
engine simply continues this line with
creme p5 and says that I'm better okay
that's true
so then that is I don't know when the
engine actually like true p8 but I was
mostly playing it because I couldn't get
the nightly form of working completely
the way it turned out it was even a
little bit better for me 96 and now we
went night c2 way after that I think
it's really terrible I don't know what
else really III is hanging it's probably
just it's not great idea yeah and tear
Queen e6 is basically a double attack d5
didn't help but you really have no good
move if I look at g4 I just take this h5
was pointed out by the comp but this is
just wrong take the pawn and this is
hanging so probably a passive move now
like here and here I'm just like better
by a mile and the centre is quite
controlled yeah I would have thought
about a noose like Queen to d5 here I'm
not sure just in the central square is
just so tempting
even though h5 makes a lot of sense
maybe just taking as good I don't know I
mean probably that's a huge range of
notes that is strong it's got a weak
King as a pawn down and so on okay guys
thanks for watching